hey you guys welcome back to flickers of
fear so
i'm sure
that i've mentioned a once or twice
probably like a million times
on this channel and elsewhere how much i
love
made for tv horror movies from the 1970s
i'm not entirely sure
what it is about them particularly
that's like so attractive to me it might
just be that they kind of take me back
to my childhood and sort of give me a
warm fuzzy feeling of nostalgia
or it could be that there's some kind of
particular vibe to them that really
resonates with me for some reason i
don't really know but i just really like
a lot of them and i just like the whole
mood around them i guess so when a
couple of you guys out there asked me to
take a look at 1973's
the norlis tapes which was a potential
series pilot made for nbc which i had
actually heard of but i had never seen
um i was intrigued enough to be like
okay that sounds pretty cool and i
actually found it if you're in the u.s
at least i'm not sure about other
countries but if you have the plex app
you can watch it on there uh for free
with ads which is where i saw it doesn't
appear to be streaming elsewhere maybe
somebody put it someplace else uh i'm
not really sure but that's where i found
it so i watched it for free legally uh
with ads so this movie has uh quite a
pedigree i was actually quite surprised
it was directed by uh dan curtis the
very famous you know dark shadows
trilogy of terror burns offerings all of
that stuff uh teleplay by william f
nolan who also wrote the screenplay of
burnt offerings and he actually wrote or
co-wrote the novel that uh logan's run
was based on
and it was adapted from a story by a
dude named fred mustard stewart which is
that's a great [ __ ] name uh who
actually wrote the novel the mephisto
waltz now i haven't read the novel but i
did remember seeing the movie and liking
it but i'd have to like watch it again
because i saw it when i was a kid so the
norales tapes was very clearly nbc's
kind of take on the paranormal
investigator battling a classic monster
formula that had actually been really
successful over on rival network abc
when they made the 1972
classic tv film the night stalker now
that was also produced by dan curtis uh
as was its sequel the knight strangler
which actually i believe dan curtis
directed that as well so dan curtis is
all over the networks like back in the
1970s now the night stalker as most
horror fans know um actually the the two
tv movies were so successful that it
spawned a series which was called
kolchak the night stalker starring
darren mcgavin as this kind of like
world weary detective character who's
always fighting like kind of like the
monster of the week um and that show
is pretty much i mean even at the time
it was beloved by many it actually got
really really good ratings even though
they stuck it in a really shitty time
slot um and it still has like a really
big cult following to this day even
though it actually ran for less than a
season so the norales tapes was also
intended to be a series along the same
lines as kolchak and it only has minor
variations from that formula like i said
this time around the paranormal
investigator character david norlis was
kind of like a journalist author type
guy uh played by roy finis
and the framing device which i actually
quite liked was a series of tapes about
different cases that he looked into
while he was working on a book
debunking the supernatural
now i actually would have loved to see
where they went with this like if it
actually went to series because it's
such an intriguing setup and like i said
i love that framing device like of the
tapes and stuff but unfortunately uh the
series wasn't picked up so all that
remains is this just single standalone
film which is actually pretty
entertaining in itself but um it is a
little frustrating because it ends in a
little bit of a cliffhanger that never
got resolved and you know obviously will
never be resolved because this was 1973
and it was a long time ago so at the
beginning of the story we're introduced
to our main character david norlis uh
and when we first meet him he's uh
not looking too good he looks like he's
maybe been on a several day bender he
can't manage to button his shirt uh
looks like he hasn't cleaned his house
and god knows how long uh you know like
i said he's having a rough time now he's
talking to his publisher his name is
sanford evans on the phone
and evans is all uh hey how's that
promised book coming along
uh evidently this publishing house gave
norales like a really big advance a year
ago
to produce a book exposing kind of like
all the fake paranormal [ __ ] like
mediums and psychics and you know
seances and [ __ ] like that that have
been going on like in i'm assuming just
in the bay area because this is set in
san francisco so he's been going around
like investigating all of these fake
mediums and so forth and he's supposed
to have produced a book about it uh you
know and like i said it was a year ago
uh norlis says well i got some bad news
for you
got some bad news and some worse news
actually he's like bad news is i haven't
even started like writing it yet and
he's like bro you've had like a year
what the [ __ ] have you been doing all
this time um he's like yeah well it's
not even that it's just that now i
realize that i can't write it uh evans
the publisher understandably asks him
what the hell do you mean by that and
this point at this point norales is like
well i need to talk to you like
immediately because tomorrow it might be
too late
so evans is just kind of like okay
whatever you say man and so he says he's
going to meet him for lunch but then
norales never shows up and then over the
next couple of days it becomes very
clear that norlis has completely
disappeared so evans who is worried
about his
friend slash investment i guess i guess
they're friends but
you know they gave him all this money
and they're like hey where's the book
bro
so evans ends up going to norlis's
rather well-appointed bayside bachelor
pad i was like wow he must there must be
like a lot of money in writing books
debunking the spiritual stuff in the 70s
if you can afford a place like that in
san francisco which was expensive even
back then but you know i digress but
anyway so while he's in this uh in the
bachelor pad
he finds a series of numbered tapes
on which norris has been recording i
guess like his notes for the proposed
book that's what some writers do they
talk into a you know recorder and then
they transcribe it later on so evans
pops in the first tape and as the tape
starts playing back like norlis's
narration the movie kind of goes back in
time to the case
that first made norlis realize that the
supernatural might actually be real
and something with which one should not
[ __ ] so that's what he meant when he
said i can't write this book now because
even though yeah i was exposing all
these fake mediums and there's a lot of
fake ones out there but i discovered
there's some real [ __ ] to it and now i'm
in trouble you know what i mean so
there's that kind of thing so we go back
to this first case which like i said
this is the pilot episode so they would
have had you know every week it would
have been like a different case like a
different tape
so norlis gets put in contact with this
wealthy widow
by the name of ellen court who's
actually played by a pre-policewoman
angie dickinson so i thought that was
kind of cool
now she wants him to investigate some
possibly paranormal shenanigans uh
involving her recently deceased sculptor
husband james who's actually played by
the renowned stuntman uh nick dimitri
and you'll figure out why later on why
he's played by stepman so one night she
tells norlis uh her german shepherd
raleigh
woke her up in the middle of the night
and when she went out to like her they
live on this like big huge massive
estate
and so the guys like the husband's
studio was kind of like in this little
converted barn like that's some way away
from the house oh and by the way he's
also buried on the thing so i guess you
can do that if you're rich enough i
suppose
so yeah so the dog barks so she goes out
there to the studio to see because i
think she hears like a noise like out of
the studio or something she thinks
somebody's like [ __ ] around out there
so
she goes out there to see what's going
on
and as she does her
lumbering blue skinned and yellow-eyed
husband now attacks her
and kills the dog i mean it's pretty
it's pretty horrible like basically like
picks up the dog and like flings it it's
not a real dog obviously but i hope not
but uh yeah it's still pretty upsetting
so i'm like why even back in the 70s
they couldn't even leave the puppies
alone god damn it but yeah so basically
flings the dog aside like a rag doll
which is [ __ ] up
now ellen uh you know she's like holy
[ __ ] and she you know shoots the dog
killing son of a [ __ ] like right in the
right in the middle of the chest like
point blank range right
but then like but then he kind of like
staggers off and then when the cops get
there they don't find a body
and there's no blood other than the
dog's blood because yeah the dog the dog
got killed the puppy got killed now the
dismissive sheriff played by claude
akins because of course he is uh he
always played the dismissive sheriff in
all of these movies i feel like um he
just says oh well what happened ma'am
was you got woke up in the middle of the
night and there maybe was an intruder in
here and you shot at him and you missed
and then he ran away maybe it was
probably just some bum looking for some
place to sleep so like don't worry
you're pretty little head about it
essentially but ellen is just trying to
tell him to like dude it was my husband
like back from the dead um and so that's
why she contacted norales because she's
like hey you look into all this
paranormal [ __ ] i want you to figure out
what the [ __ ] going on why is my dead
ass husband like wandering around now
shortly after this uh a random young
woman who doesn't have anything like she
really is a random young woman she's
just some woman that works at a store or
something and she's kind of getting off
work and going out to her car like to go
home and she gets killed when the
zombified husband attacks her from the
back seat of her car and then that makes
the the car like crash into a tree now
when the cops get there and they take
the body out of the wreck they discover
that the woman has actually been
completely drained of blood which you
know i i'm no forensic scientist but i'm
pretty sure that a car accident doesn't
do that so now the sheriff again uh is
less dismissive this time but still a
little bit dismissive but he's very
befuddled also and he basically tells
everybody that we'll listen um yeah
let's keep this little detail on the
down low until we get everything sorted
out don't tell the press don't tell him
he's like you can tell him that she was
murdered because it's very clear that
she was strangled and that all her blood
was missing uh so that obviously the
crash didn't kill her but he's like yeah
don't tell him about like all the blood
being messing missing because it's like
yeah we don't need that like [ __ ]
[ __ ] show coming down on us while we
don't exactly know what's going on so as
the story progresses
it comes to light that before his death
james court and this is actually what he
ended up dying of he got some kind of i
don't even think they say what it is in
the movie but he got some kind of like
crippling and very like fast-acting
disease
and while he was declining uh he sort of
like in desperation turned to the occult
in an attempt to stave off death i guess
now through a contact at the gallery
that handled his sculpture so i'm
assuming it's just like it's like the
gallery owner i guess i don't think it's
his agent or anything uh he gets
introduced to this antique dealer slash
medium type lady uh who's called
mademoiselle jekyll jekyll
jake eel i can't remember how they
pronounced it um and she's actually
played by vanetta mcgee as soon as she
popped up on screen i'm like blacula she
was in blacula so i like recognized her
right away because i love that movie so
yeah so she was in this as well now uh
she ended up giving him like some kind
of ancient egyptian scarab ring
that james insisted in his will that he
be buried with after he dies so while
all of this information is being
uncovered uh more people including the
gallery owner and ellen's sister uh get
killed like they turn up dead
so ellen and norlis actually go back
into james's studio to see if there's
something unusual there they missed the
first time that's maybe gonna explain
this weird [ __ ] that's going on
and when they go in there they find this
sculpture of like a devily
superhero looking creature guy dude uh
that actually wasn't there a couple days
before and they're sitting here going
hey like all this clay is still kind of
damp
so that means that james like zombified
james has been toddling out of his
coffin at night and working on his
sculptures they do find out too that
like because like i said the dude is
buried like in a vault on the property
and they find out later there's all
these like underground tunnels so he's
just popping out the coffin and like
going down under the ground and like
coming out in his studio and all this
other kind of stuff so uh so he's not it
turns out though that even though he's
coming back from the dead to do the
sculpture he's not just doing it for
shits and giggles he's actually like
what mademoiselle jekyll tells norlis
later on is that undead james actually
made a pact with a demon named sargoth
which i thought was very funny um to
sort of make this kick-ass kind of
life-size vessel out of clay and human
blood like mixed together
and you know the demon is gonna like
manifest in this statue like a golem i
guess it's kind of like that and so
they're like if james does that then
he'll get like eternal life so it's like
an exchange deal with the devil kind of
deal so that's why all the victims were
found with no blood uh james had been
kind of using his kills in service of
his immortality giving art project he'd
been like draining all their blood
somehow i'm not really sure because i
thought at one point they shouldn't like
drinking it like a vampire but then i'm
like what does he go like spit it back
into the does he just like hold it in
his cheeks like a chipmunk or i don't
really know i'm thinking too much about
it i'm sure so this demon sargoth
sorry that's just a really funny demon
name so the demon actually does uh
manifest briefly in the world he ends up
looking a little bit like i mean because
it's a tv movie from the 1970s so the
makeup and stuff prosthetics isn't going
to be like the best so he looks a little
bit like rust-colored 1970s incredible
hulk with kind of like a halloween style
devil cape on type of thing it looked
like he also kind of had like like tidy
whities on too or like little superhero
panties or something i don't know i
couldn't really tell like because i
didn't really see him that good when he
was like in his human form i just saw
him when he was in his clay in human
blood form so i was just kind of like
okay that seems like an interesting
outfit like that's that's why he kind of
like gave me the gave me the impression
that he was like a superhero so he does
actually like pop out the thing and like
you know the the statue comes to life
and everything but apparently the demon
is thwarted by norales like using some
kind of magic potion that he made but
also like mixed with fire like he makes
this kind of circle around the statue
and then like with the potion and then
like he lights it on fire and the demon
can't get out or something like that so
uh because this movie though was
intended to be the beginning of a series
it's
left unstated
whether the demon was actually destroyed
or sent back or whatever or
whether sargoth was going to be like a
recurring baddie like as the story
continued so you don't really know it
seems like he got destroyed like they
find
zombified james's bones in the thing
like you know prompting which i would
prompt to go to the cop and be like see
i told you my dad has middles like
walking around but they didn't find
anything they didn't find like any demon
bones i don't know if demons have bones
whatever so like i said i'm thinking too
much about it so anyway so i don't so i
don't really know i don't i don't really
know if he was gonna like come back as
like a recurring like oh this is like
the big demon that they're gonna like
fight it then so the film actually ends
with the publisher evans popping in the
second tape the second norales tape in
which norris is going on you know hey
chapter two
going on to a new chapter and talking
about a different case but of course
we'll never find out what that case was
gonna be and we never found out this was
the thing that that bothered me and that
it's like i said this is uh that was
like a cliffhanger was that you know
remember i said at the beginning like
nor listed actually like disappeared you
know so you never actually find out like
where norrilis disappeared to and if
this whatever supernatural underworld or
the demon or whatever that he uncovered
had something to do with where he went
like is he dead is somebody keeping him
somewhere like so you'll never like find
out because the series i'm assuming was
going to be his publisher listening to
all his tapes and then at the end like
in the season finale i'm assuming they
would have found out like where he was
and like gone to rescue him or whatever
but like i said you're never gonna know
because this was it now i will say like
the norlis tapes it isn't quite as fun
as the night stalker or the cold shack
series just because that was like
funnier that had like a lot more like
dark humor to it and this one is doesn't
have any humor it's very played very
straight but i will say that it is a
very very effectively creepy
kind of slab of 70s made for tv goodness
which like i said i love all these kind
of uh made for tv movies from the 70s
has very decent acting in it has some
actually like some really great suspense
some very well-staged action sequences
and the look of the kind of vampire
zombie undead dude you know it's crude
by today's standards but it's still
pretty damn good and uh you know the
stuntman nick dimitri is very imposing
like he was a big dude and uh he
actually like provides some really good
scares like for example like when you
pull some the curtains aside and his
creepy ass face is like on the other
side of the window or you know when he
busts through a door unexpectedly or
like pops out someone's backseat or
something like that so he is actually
like very imposing and like kind of
scary and the makeup is like kind of
scary looking even though like i said
it's crude by today's standards but it's
the 70s it's a tv movie what are you
gonna do so like i said it's really a
shame that this didn't get picked up as
a series because
i really did like that conceit of norlis
and his collection of case tapes and i
really would have liked to see where
they went with it and what ended up
happening to norales like where the [ __ ]
he went to
but i mean at least we got this little
movie and it's you know it's pretty
[ __ ] good um it's a perfectly
satisfying diversion in its own right
it's just a shame like i said it's like
i said it's not as good as the coal
shack movies just because those were
like funnier and more so this one was
more serious and roy thinness is not
like he he's kind of a more of a very
like world where he's not like real
sardonic or anything he's just very
serious and very weary and stuff like
that but it's along the same lines so if
you like that kind of thing which you
know like later on would go and be like
the x-files and stuff like that this is
like
proto-x-files kind of stuff um you know
what i feel like you know all the coal
shack night stalker and all that kind of
stuff any kind of like paranormal
monster of the week like paranormal
investigator meets monster of the week
kind of thing so it kind of all started
with this uh kind of thing and i can see
why nbc wanted their own version of the
of the abc like cole shack stuff because
it was so popular but unfortunately it
just didn't work out but actually this
is um an actually really good 70s tv
movie and i enjoyed it very much so
thanks you guys for recommending it i
mean i probably would have got around to
it eventually but it might have taken a
while if you guys probably hadn't
brought it up so i'm glad that i
actually got to watch it so that'll do
it for this flickers of fear and i will
see you guys again on the next one
bye